et on va plus loin avec ses 2 l'imam
directeur du mensuel afrique magazine
bonjour hier soir et face à vos bruno
daroux de la rédaction de france 24
bonjour bruno roussel le proche orient
secoués par la mort du journaliste de la
chaîne al jazeera sherine à boîte les
couvrir un raid des soldats israéliens à
djénine lorsqu'elle a été mortellement
touché par un tir al jazeera accusent
les forces israéliennes d'avoir tué de
façon délibérée et de sang-froid sa
journaliste vedette ce que dément l'état
hébreu qui pointe lui des tirs de
combattants palestiniens mais des
légendes tout de même une enquête
écoutez la réaction d'une de ses
collègues suivie de celle du premier
ministre israélien naftali bennet
du vernis repris hier un ultime hommage
rendu à chérir d'avouer son nouveau
résonne partout dans les territoires
palestiniens de gaza un ramallah son
portrait est affiché comme un symbole la
journaliste était l'un des visages les
plus connus de la chaîne qatarie al
jazira certains de ses collègues se sont
effondrés à l'unss de la niveau
cherub sont africaines
mais duncan
diamond jenness des tournées de l'espoir
lorsque nous sartène à la malle réunis
dans la maison familiale de beit hanina
à jérusalem est les proches de shirin
aboa clés sont un conteur
campagne
chez rim a bouclé étaient en reportage
ici dans le camp de réfugiés de jénine
au nord de la cisjordanie occupée elle
couvrait une opération antiterroriste
lorsqu'elle a été abattue
châtain a annoncé était à ses côtés elle
témoigne
d'un changement a commencé à
aller mieux je suis protégé dans le
métrage faisant un arbre et elle s'était
à chaque fois qu'on essaie de
s'approcher de l'armée israélienne
[Musique]
le chef de la mission de l'union
européenne dans les territoires
palestiniens appellent à une enquête
rapide vient dépendantes
pour l'instant pas d' enquête
indépendante il est une enquête
effectivement mais diligentée par tsahal
en son sein naftali bennet lui s'est
exprimé plus tôt dans la journée pour
lui il s'agit bien de tirs palestiniens
c'est en tout cas eu qu'il incrimine
écoutez le ils ont fait des dégâts mais
malheureusement la journaliste d'al
jazeera sherine à bois clé a été tués
dans les échanges de tirs
l'autorité palestinienne s'est précipité
pour accuser israël pour sa mort et le
président de l'autorité palestinienne a
porté des accusations sans fondement
contre israël avant qu aucune enquête
n'a été menée halpern tous les maris
chauny selon les informations que nous
avons réuni on semble probable que la
journaliste était abattu par des
palestiniens armés
cependant pour révéler la vérité une
véritable enquête doit être menée les
palestiniens l'empêchent actuellement
enfin les steinbach à la base m on est
médecin et des manifestations de
protestation dont était éclaté depuis à
à gaza ramallah ainsi qu'ailleurs dans
le monde arabe comme à tunis par exemple
l'onu l'union européenne et les etats
unis appellent tu as une enquête
indépendante il est essentiel bruno
daroux de faire toute la lumière sur les
responsabilités dans cette affaire oui
il est essentiel il serait essentiel
va-t-on dur parce que le problème c'est
que la journaliste a déjà été enterrés
donc en plus il faudrait déterré son
corps ce qui évidemment ne serait pas
simple vu le fut le contexte actuel il
n'y a pas à ce stade d'enquêté
internationale et indépendante donc
c'est un problème donc évidemment on en
est réduit à version des faits des
israéliens contre version des faits
palestinien est évidemment dans le
contexte actuel où il y à des tensions
très fortes entre palestiniens et
israéliens depuis plusieurs semaines et
encore ces jours ci dans le quartier de
silwan à jérusalem est évidemment ça ne
peut ça ne peut qu'attiser ces tensions
d'autant plus que
cherry nabua clé était donc la
journaliste de la chaîne al jazeera qui
est vu dans le dans tout le monde arabe
donc c'était c'est une journaliste
extrêmement connu et qui mené ces
enquêtes c'est qui faisait ses
reportages sur notamment la la situation
des palestiens depuis des années elle
était elle-même d'ailleurs palestinienne
et américaine à la foi chrétienne zale
imams cet événement risque de provoquer
un nouvel embrasement cet événement va
avoir un impact d'abord par la stature
du personnage c'est à dire que
contrairement à de nombreuses victimes
anonymes
il y en a tous les jours tu es ou non
directement par l'armée israélienne ou
victimes d'attentats que ça
c'est ce journaliste était une figure
d'algesiras c'était quelqu'un qui était
là depuis des années qui faisait partie
du quotidien des gens du quotidien dans
les territoires occupés mais dans tout
le monde arabe auquel elle avait une
véritable stature donc sa sas ça va
compter
les circonstances et le moment comme
disait bruno du drame ça va compter
beaucoup parce que le moment il ya un
vrai moment de tension avec des
attentats en israël et d répression dans
les territoires occupés donc on est dans
ce cycle classique et puis à les
circonstances du drame qui sont quand
même
excusez moi qui sont quand même
extrêmement troublantes les témoignages
des gens qui étaient avec elle moi je
veux bien la théorie du complot mais
quand même ils disent tous la même chose
le l'état-major israélien a reculé cet
après-midi en disant qu'ils n'étaient
pas tout à fait sûr et qu'il fallait
voir là la précision du tir passait des
choses qui sont extrêmement troublantes
et et qui pose la question encore et
encore et encore de la protection des
journalistes mais des palestiniens dans
les territoires occupés c'est pas la
première fois que ça arrive c'est pour
ça que la question de la question de l'
enquête indépendante et centrale parce
que sinon on connaît les comportements
de sahel serbe a créé toutes sortes de
trucs on va étouffer le dossier et s'il
dit c'est pas la première fois que ça
arrivait donc si on veut aller au bout
il faut que vous savez il ya beaucoup
d'ouvertures en ce moment entre l'israël
et les pays arabes il ya beaucoup de
choses qui se passent etc
mais si ce processus doit marcher il
faut aussi qu'il ya une justice est un
droit pour les palestiniens dans les
territoires occupés en israël se pose
même pas l'action des palestine et
israéliens palestiniens on a déjà des
territoires occupés que ces incidents
n'aboutissent jamais ou quasiment jamais
à une condamnation à une mise en examen
à une dénonciation des troupes
israéliennes quand elles agissent si
c'est le cas dans ce cas la côte elles
agissent de cette manière là c'est un
problème essentiel qui protègent ces
gens là les protéger son analyse les
images fournies par tsahal pour pour
justifier leur soi-disant échange de
chèques et palestiniens en fait ce
serait produite à 300 m du lieu s'élève
dans lequel la journaliste a été célèbre
sellem a dit c'est pas le même endroit à
saint clair et net donc c'est
lorsque c'était au tour du camp de
jénine où il y avait des mouillages
régulièrement en plus il a encore plus
que où il ya régulièrement des
interventions de l'armée israélienne
parce que c'est vrai que c'est un des
camps les plus radicaux et dans le
contexte des attaques qui elles qui ont
lieu en israël aujourd'hui qui ont eu
lieu la semaine dernière et c'est donc
celle sajoo mais encore une fois
les journalistes les résidents les gens
qui vivent dans les territoires de par
quel droit sont ils protégés
c'est la question effectivement et on
espère avoir avoir une réponse dans les
prochains jours au proche orient
toujours la russie se cherche des alliés
face aux sanctions occidentales sergueï
lavrov est en tournée dans le monde
arabe après le maghreb et alger hier le
chef de la diplomatie russe et à oman
aujourd'hui l'occasion d'un appel aux
autres pays producteurs comme moscou
d'hydrocarbures à ne pas faire de cadeau
aux occidentaux écoutez
nous avons assez de clients qui achètent
nos énergies fossiles et nous allons
travailler avec eux laissez les
occidentaux payer plus qui le paient à
la russie et laisser les expliquer à
leurs citoyens pourquoi ils devraient
s'appauvrir
hier il était en algérie vu par certains
en europe comme une alternative possible
au gaz russe bruno daroux la russie ne
compte pas laisser les européens
l'isoler encore moins l'appauvrir non
parce que là la russie de vladimir
poutine utilise larmes des hydrocarbures
a son propre profil directement mais
elle essaye d'éviter aussi que les
européens voir les américains mais
surtout les européens puissent
contourner justement la pression qu'elle
exerce sur eux d'où ces visites en
algérie à oman la russie aussi joue sa
propre diplomatie en quelque sorte soit
qui ait hérité de l'histoire soit qui
est plus récente une diplomatie fait à
la fois de deux positionnements
stratégiques d'intérêt économique bien
compris de part et d'autre et doudou le
fait d'ailleurs que les pays comme
l'algérie ou les émirats arabes unis
restent quand même d'une l'arabie
saoudite va en parler mais reste quand
même d'une grande prudence dans la crise
actuelle refusant de condamner
publiquement l'invasion de l'ukraine
cherchant ne pas trop froisser moscou
dans le cas de l'algérie qui fournit je
crois un peu plus de 10 % du gaz
européen bourse qui est peu comparé aux
45 47% fourni par la russie au pays
européens mais l'algérie a dit attention
nous on n'a pas des capacités limitées
donc ne vous attendez pas à des miracles
quoi est donc là effectivement sergueï
lavrov il vient essayer de constituer un
front alors pas anti occidentale mais en
tout cas deux pays qui va presque dans
une tradition on en revient presque à
une tradition de du temps de l'urss 1re
constitue cette relation avec les pays
arabes pour contrer ce que fait
l'occident pour nuire à moscou dia de
séguéla man fait est annoncé à tunis
puis il a décidé d'annuler sa visite on
sait pourquoi je sais pas trop en faire
on sait pas trop s'il ya eu une
véritable page n'est pas dans les
secrets de l'aide du palais de carthage
10 dont les secrets du ministère des
affaires étrangères il ya eu semble-t-il
des velléités est ce qu'elles ont été
réellement diplomatique concrètes pas
concrète ce que ça ait vraiment lieu ce
qui est sûr c'est que en tunisie on sent
tous les cas une espèce d'écartèlement
entre la raison qui consisterait d'abord
les tunisiens ont fait partie de la
fameuse conférence de
rammstein des alliés l'aider autant les
tunisiens ont un statut d'allié
privilégié non membres avec d'autres
pays comme je crois le maroc
donc voila et puis la relation à
l'europe qui est absolument essentiel
pour la tunisie et la france premier
partenaire commercial l'europe premier
bailleur de fonds on a besoin du fmi on
a besoin de la banque mondiale on a
besoin de tout le monde en ce moment et
est en même temps il ya une toute une
toute une tout un espèce de discours sur
le fait que voilà on a des mauvaises
relations avec les etats-unis et
peut-être que la russie d'adopter à
cette idée que la russie pourrait être
un contrepoids
parce qu'il ya dans ce dans ce monde
émergent dans ces mondes émergents cette
recherche d'un contrepoids à la j'allais
dire à la toute-puissance euro
américaine
c'est pas facile parce que les russes
ont peu de choses aujourd'hui à offrir
de l'énergie s'ils veulent bien la
vendent moins cher ils le font avec
l'inde mais c'est pas sûr qu'ils le
feront avec tout le monde du blé s'ils
veulent bien en donner sur le plan
économique ils n'ont pas les moyens que
kylie a pu six ans une guerre sur les
bras ils ont sur le plan militaire ils
sont aussi contraints par la guerre et
puis tout où tous ces pays sont dans un
système quand même c'est vrai qu'ils
aient dominé par des mécanismes
économiques et financiers et politiques
qui sont largement sous le contrôle des
pays du g7 et en particulier de
washington et ses alliés européens donc
on attend ça et puis il ya une grosse
pression qui skie qui s'appuie sur
beaucoup de pays africains en ce moment
au cerf ou dans le cas de l'algérie ce
particulier puisque l'algérie c'est un
ami historique ses 60 ans ils ont fêté
d'ailleurs je crois la visite était pour
fêter les 60 ans du traité d'amitié mais
mais les africains sont entre le marteau
et l'enclume celeron leur demande de
prendre des décisions et de faire des
choix sur une guerre qui les concernent
pas forcément directement et qui a un
impact économique dont on va sentir
petit à petit les faits redoutable le
prix de l'énergie le prix de
l'alimentation l'inflation qui se
répercute à tous les niveaux c'est à
dire le prix d'une cargaison augmente le
prix d'un bateau augmente tout augmente
et l'afrique est fragile 80% de
l'afrique est fragile aujourd'hui dos
comment comment sortir de ce piège
économique dans lequel ils sont poussés
petit à petit c'est du raid sûr et ça
pose aussi bruno à la question des
pétromonarchies du golfe dont la russie
s'est rapproché dernièrement oui là
aussi s'est rapproché et on peut penser
notamment aux émirats arabes unis et à
l'arabie saoudite en fait dans le cas de
l'arabie saoudite par exemple qui fait
partir appelons le comme de l'opep et
qui en lien très étroit avec moscou
alors qu'à de l'opep plus ce que moscou
est un peu à la tête des dix partenaires
n'appartenant pas à l'opep donc les deux
pays se parle beaucoup de pétrole est
actuellement l'arabie saoudite fait de
la résistance face aux pressions de sans
doute de washington pour augmenter la
production le robinet pour quoi ils sont
faits la politique actuellement menée
par moscou d'un certain côté fait que
les prix montent et que ça profite à son
économie que pour le moment bal à
l'arabie saoudite ne veut ne pas ouvrir
les vannes dans le cas des émirats
arables unis il ya ça aussi il ya le
pétrole le gaz il ya aussi des intérêts
un peu stratégique de 2,2 régime assez
autoritaire finalement qui s'entendent
bien qu'ils s'entendent bien entre eux
donc voilà c'est pour ça que sergueï
lavrov il va aussi dans cette zone la
guerre en ukraine elle pourrait
redessiner les vieilles encore six
autres hommes par les accords d'abraham
les etats unis qui bouge dans tous les
sens dans le cas du golfe moi je pense
franchement qu'on a à faire et au cartel
pétrolier largement et puis aussi pour
laisser odien et pour les émirati de
montrer des signes d'indépendance par
rapport à washington en disant on n'est
pas vos on n'est pas vos sbires et puis
il ya aussi les intérêts russes
financier dans une ville comme dubaï il
ya des intérêts russes financier amont
autrement des oligarques e ligue arabe
des photos les voies ils sont à la
piscine sur la plage bon donc voilà
après encore une fois la réalité du
monde d'aujourd'hui c'est pas je sais
que c'est un peu brutal c'est pas la
russie c'est les états unis la chine et
l'europe au milieu et 6 ainsi à une
reconstruction j'allais dire stratégique
d'un certain nombre de pays d'alliance
etc c'est que voilà ça se joue entre
d'un côté washington de l'autre côté
pékin et puis nos quelques amis au
milieu qui est au même essaye de se
mettre donc je vois pas arrêt à ligny
mans je vois d amitié traditionnelle
jouée et puis je pense que les pays
émergents ils ont dit qu ils ont des
coûts des problèmes vous parler de la
crise économique qui s'approche
l'app la plupart des pays émergents qui
sont endettés on voit les taux d'intérêt
se monte monte monte et ça ça annonce
une crise majeure de l'endettement dans
les pays émergents donc à la fin des
fins on va revenir là où ça se décide et
là où ça se décide c'est le fmi c'est la
banque mondiale c'est washington c'est
la fed c'est l'union européenne et donc
on pourrait nous émergents faire un peu
pression à vos côtés vous avez fait la
guerre aux bons mais est ce qu'on peut
avoir des appuis est ce que par exemple
sur cette histoire de taux d'intérêt qui
exposait ce qu'on peut protéger les pays
les plus fragiles est ce que le plan
français sur l'alimentaire est ce qu'on
peut pas les tendres et on pourrait
jouer un peu avec ça à dire bon nous on
est ouvert on veut bien discuter avec
vous mais aidez nous dans la situation
où on est aujourd'hui
d'autant que la russie finalement est
plutôt affaibli alors qu'il est si l'on
regarde vraiment la situation sur le
terrain bruno vous qui avez suivi tout
au long de cette journée là sur
l'évolution de la situation en ukraine
c'est peut-être à fait non plus pour
faciliter les alliances avec l'étranger
oui parce que certains certains de ces
pays regardent aussi effectivement avec
beaucoup beaucoup de prudence et
d'attentisme comment évaluer la
situation sur le terrain où on s'en
doute écouté le discours de vladimir
poutine hier bon bien difficile de lire
dans mes options de du maître du kremlin
mais enfin on voit bien que ça continue
à bouger très fortement la autour de
autour de desa cette fois-ci peut-être
poussé vers la transnistrie donc et
qu'en même temps l'armée ukrainienne
pousse des contre-offensives à kharkiv
que la deuxième ville très importante
que ça bouge même à kherson que
nikolaïev t'es pas encore tombés dont
pour qu'on verra des savoie là et que
les ukrainiens non seulement ils
résistent l'armée et toute la population
derrière et puis avec tous les armements
qui arrivent plus à décision prise
annoncé hier par joe biden à laleu
sallois près bail qui fait que là pour
le coup les vannes financières sont
littéralement ouverte et que ça va plus
vite que lors des procédures
traditionnelles avec le congrès bref la
situation extrêmement mouvante rien
n'est gagné pour
pour la russie 1 après presque trois
mois de guerre donc effectivement il
reste dans une position très très
prudent ça compte ça aussi la
désillusion que certains ont pu avoir
sur la force supposée de la russie après
trois mois deux mois et demi défensif
enfin je pense que pour le
fallait plusieurs positions l'ailé pour
les américains il ya clairement toute
une école qui dit c'est le moment de les
rats dati née et de les rendre
inoffensif pour pour 50 ou 60 ans et de
les ramener dans le camp et que ses
avocats il ya cette école après il ya
une école française mépris de leurs
menaces de la menace nucléaire qui
lorsque j'allais dire que et puis
l'école française qui essaient de
trouver des compromis mais il ya quand
même une puissance la première puissance
nucléaire au monde dont on ne mesure pas
encore une fois on l'a dit souvent sur
ce plateau dont on ne mesure pas encore
une fois l'état de stabilité intérieure
c'est à moi je je je ne vais pas je suis
pas kremlinologues et je veux me
m'avancerai pas sur la criminal crème
lino logis mais je ne sais pas à quel
point ce régime est stable ne sait pas à
quel point il supporte une mauvaise
situation militaire je vois que le ton
des télévisions russes je lisais sur
twitter qui est une source assez
intéressante mais j'espère qu'elle ne va
pas tout ravager mais qui est une source
assez intéressante en ce moment sur la
guerre comme comment le commentaire de
des grandes télévisions russes d'état
est en train de changer en faisant
porter le chapeau de la situation aux
militaires pour pour j'ai presque pour
protéger le politique et vadim la police
donc on sait pas trop ce qui se passe et
donc je comprends la position
d'attentisme d'un certain de gens osant
nous est encore une fois pour 80 % de
l'humanité c'est pas leur guerre
c'est quelque chose qui va les impacts
et qui va perturber les équilibres qui
va créer d d d d d d vague de crise
économique probable et les menteurs
alimentaire énergétique ans je vous
parlais des taux d'intérêt donc voilà
mais c'est pas notre guerre donc voyons
ce qui se passe
ce sera le mot de la fin merci à lima
merci bruno daroux on va plus loin c'est
terminé on se retrouve nous dans trois
minutes pour un nouveau journal dans
parisien